♪ [upbeat music plays]
Alex Willen: Box is a cloud content
management company.
We provide online storage and
collaboration features for businesses.
So, it's like a file system in the cloud,
but with a software layer on top of it
that allows you to easily
share content with others.
And while we provide sort of
the online version of a hard drive
that allows you to store
your content online,
Chrome takes it one step further
by taking the entire operating
system online.
Jeremy Glassenberg: Our first integration
with Chrome was a single sign-on solution,
so that any Google user
who was utilizing Chrome--
either the Chrome OS or the browser--
has an easy way of accessing Box
through the App Store.
So, we enjoy the fact that any files
you traditionally work with
through the Chrome OS
can easily go right into Box
and from there,
interact with your customers,
with your co-workers,
and with the other Google services
that you're used to.
We especially like the latest update
that Chrome's providing,
where if you have content on your desktop,
on your Chrome device,
you're getting it into your Chrome device.
It's very easy to get it
from Chrome onto the cloud.
And with the Box APIs,
as was acknowledged
by the Google Chrome team,
it was very easy to connect
our APIs to Chrome's APIs
so that just in a matter of days,
we were able to get files
uploading from Chrome into Box.
Alex Willen: So yeah, we're very excited
to be integrated into Chrome OS.
It's pretty simple,
which is the way we like things.
If you have, for example, a USB drive,
and you plug it into your Chrome OS notebook,
you'll see that content in Chrome OS
in their file browser.
You easily just select a file,
click "Upload to Box,
pick what directory you want it
to go into and it uploads right away.
It's a very simple, two-click process.
00:01:39.125,00:00:00.000